it's unforgivable isn't it um there are
people not just on metastate but
elsewhere in the borough who are living
in homes which are not really fit for
human habitation dampen mold is a big
problem but I want to work with the
council and with others in order to make
sure that our BH is in a position to to
do those repairs and to make sure that
people are in decent and in safe homes
and of course it's a situation not just
in Rochdale but in other parts of the
Northwest and indeed across the UK that
we do urgently need to address well I'm
concerned about the way in which rbh is
operated altogether the chief executive
has now gone and I think that there are
searching questions that need to be
asked and that's why the regulator is
looking into how rbh of operators the
most important thing is making sure that
people in the borough get the housing
they deserve and I'm looking forward to
talking to councilors who I know from
every party want to make sure the
situation is put right